Sí es que el 11 de mayo termina la
emergencia de salud pública en Estados
Unidos y por consecuencia termina la
medida del título 42 que le permitía al
gobierno estadounidense expulsar a
migrantes que considerara como riesgo de
salud pública En total en estos años que
la política del título 42 ha estado en
pie se han expulsado a dos millones y
medio de migrantes Y pues lo que dicen
muchos analistas en la frontera es que
una vez
se cierre este capítulo del título 42 se
espera una aliada migratoria Incluso se
habla de hasta 10.000 personas Al Día
10.000 migrantes que estarían esperando
ya en no en el norte de méxico cerca de
la frontera con Estados Unidos para que
una vez se acabe el título 42 pues
entonces pasen la frontera y puedan
aplicar al asilo en este país lo que
quiere Estados Unidos Entonces es tratar
de encontrar soluciones para prevenir y
estar obligada migratoria y una de ellas
es abrir centros de centros de centros
de de
procesamiento migratorio en Guatemala y
en Colombia para que los migrantes en
estos dos países pues puedan desde allá
aplicar a permisos laborales asilo y a
programas de reunificación familiar esto
pues obviamente va a tener consecuencias
de Cara a la logística que Estados
Unidos va a tener que implementar en
Guatemala y en Colombia para desde estos
países tratar de prevenir estas oleadas
migratorias a Estados Unidos bueno otro
punto que llamó la atención es en este
anuncio es el papel que tendrían Canadá
y España en la iniciativa y también le
pregunto Qué consecuencias tiene para
biden la eliminación del título 42 justo
ahora que lanzó su campaña la reelección
exactamente y además la próxima semana
en el congreso los republicanos van a
aprobar que tienen mayoría en la cámara
de representantes un nuevo plan
migratorio así que pues es bastante
delicado esta finalización del título 42
de Cara a la misión política religión de
biden Además porque la política y La
retórica de los republicanos es vincular
las oleadas migratorias con el problema
de fentanilo en Estados Unidos así que
sin duda ese va a ser el caballo de
batalla que van a usar los republicanos
para contrarrestar a los demócratas en
las próximas elecciones pero sí Canadá y
España Pues están de acuerdo si lo
anunció el gobierno de Estados Unidos
que están de acuerdo en que migrantes
que sean procesados en estos centros en
Guatemala y en Colombia puedan no
solamente ir directamente a Estados
Unidos sino también a estos dos países
además Washington dice que está hablando
con otros países a nivel internacional
para que también acojan migrantes y que
no sean no solamente sea Colombia y
Guatemala los países donde se procesen a
estos inmigrantes antes de que lleguen a
Estados Unidos sino que sean más países
en Centroamérica y en América Latina